alerta máxima en el aeropuerto
internacional de schiphol de amsterdam
este viernes se hicieron obligatorias
las pruebas de kobe 19 para todos los
pasajeros procedentes de sudáfrica
los viajeros estuvieron atrapados
durante horas en el aeródromo sin riesgo
alguno por la propagación de la variante
omicron recién detectada
las personas que se han sometido a las
pruebas reciben los resultados por
teléfono y no saben lo que va a pasar
después la gente está cada vez más
alterada quieren comida y hacen saber su
malestar de los 600 pasajeros examinados
61 resultaron positivos para el virus y
tuvieron que entrar en cuarentena por el
momento no es posible determinar si eran
portadores de la variante o micro
el miedo comienza a crecer en toda
europa ahora con varios casos detectados
en alemania bélgica reino unido e italia
mientras se analizan unos 50 casos
sospechosos la organización mundial de
la salud expresó su preocupación por la
variante que según los expertos podría
ser altamente contagiosa benítez
tenemos que averiguar si hay que
modificar las vacunas todo esto se puede
hacer bastante rápido porque algunas de
ellas son fácilmente modificables pzifer
y modernas han anunciado que tardarían
aproximadamente tres meses modificar sus
vacunas para combatir la nueva variante